[Music]
after watching this video you should be
prepared to identify the two primary
reasons to measure social media efforts
and use them to guide your digital
analytics strategy to explain why
economic value is about more than how
many products you sell to an outline the
four primary social media specific
metrics and their purposes and to
identify the appropriate applause
indicators on major social channels
let's begin lesson to social media
specific metrics and back in part one of
this series we talked a little bit about
what exactly it is we meant by
measurement that it's about more than
just so-called measuring a channel it's
about measuring the impact of the
channel it's figuring out how to find
value because what happens all too often
when we talk about measurements is
people get focused on those those easy
to see social media metrics that are
just right there in front of you how
many followers do you have on Pinterest
you know how many likes did you get on
that Facebook post how many thumbs-up
happened on YouTube and again those have
value and we'll get to those but
measurement is about more than a
predefined set of formulas that everyone
needs to follow yes there's going to be
some things that are across the board
but really when it comes down to
creating a measurement plan for your
campaign or for your company your goals
are going to define what has value so to
get things rolling you need to be able
to ask yourself a couple questions
because as with everything else we've
learned it'll all come down to what
works best for you what your business
needs to have happen so you need to ask
yourself things like what is it that you
need to know where can you get that type
of information and what will you use the
data for because if you don't take the
time to ask these questions it becomes
all too easy to find yourself in that
place of analysis paralysis where
there's just so much information coming
in and you really don't know how you're
actually going to leverage it or do
something with it
now there's two main goals when it comes
to social media and a lot of this is
about perspective because there's a
million different things you can measure
but
all comes down to two key points of
value the first one is the idea of
whether or not your efforts were worth
it the primary reason we measure our
social media efforts is to answer that
question with the amount of time and
money and effort and staffing that we
put into it
rewarded by a positive enough ROI to
justify that investment that's the first
and foremost thing we always want to
look at is are we wasting our time or is
what we're doing actually helping us
progress further the number two purpose
of measurement is improvement this is
the other key thing that we're looking
for is to gain the knowledge needed to
make our efforts more effective the next
time around basically to create that
process of learning refining and then
relaunching our efforts when it comes to
looking at measurement and sort of
digital analytics from the social media
side there are definitely some areas
that are very particular to this area of
marketing in fact way back in 2011
Avinash Kaushik introduced four key
measurement points that could be used
for social media and there's still a
great starting point today if you want
to read the whole article that he put
together you'll see the link down there
at the bottom tiny URL slash
FL - measure that'll take you right to
it but I'm also going to walk you
through sort of what they are and what
they look like in terms of practical
application so basically he boiled down
the idea of sort of the high level
social media measurement into the area
of economic value conversation rate
amplification rate and applause rate now
when it comes to economic value the
basic idea here is to look at the total
revenue that's being produced by your
efforts while also considering the cost
savings that's provided by those efforts
because keep in mind a lot of times with
social media it's not necessarily the
direct value of how many products did we
sell but it's also how your social media
efforts
the connection points that are created
there what it enables to happen within
your business so sometimes that's direct
sales you know clearly you want to track
the sales to come from your social media
promotions so you know if you you've put
something out on Facebook specially if
you're you know using discount codes and
stuff it's fairly easy to go in and
track that to see okay how much revenue
came from this particular sale or this
particular campaign but sometimes it's
about saving money through the way you
leverage social media maybe you're
reducing call center traffic maybe
you're having reduced brick and mortar
hours because you're doing more selling
online maybe you're using it to test
products before you launch so there's a
great quote from one of the marketing
team over at Infusionsoft that talked
about the differences that happened when
they made use of social media to engage
the customers to answer questions you
know to not necessarily have everything
go through customer service agents and
they said two years before they started
the initiative they had approximately
one customer service agent for every 55
customers and a 77% customer
satisfaction rating now after they
implemented their social media
parameters they found that the ratio
could drop to one agent to 172 customers
and they actually saw a bump up to 87
percent customer satisfaction rating
said Infusionsoft social media
initiative save the company millions of
dollars in overall support cost and
produced a 10 percent increase in
customer satisfaction so again that
comes back to that economic value that's
created through the actions taken in
social media
now the same way that some companies
find that they really pull some nice
economic value in from may be lowering
customer service needs or you know
changing call center costs a lot of
times companies also get that media
benefit so a great example of this is
Kraft who estimates that it pulls 1.1
billion ad impressions per year at four
times better ROI from their content
marketing and social media efforts than
they do from their targeted advertising
so again it becomes about shifting
things over a little bit so that you're
still getting that benefit but there's
not quite as much money going in behind
it and that comes into the economic
value side of things now understanding
conversation value means understanding
that it's more than engagement because
most of us consider sort of the
conversation that happens in social
media to be engagement and there's truth
to that but we're looking a little
deeper at the the idea of whether people
are commenting on your posts responding
to your updates and otherwise engaging
with you and there's a lot of different
ways we can look at that one of those is
the idea of conversational response
so are they replying to what you're
putting out there are people engaged or
your social posts met with silence you
know it's not uncommon for us to see
this happening on channels like Facebook
where people put out an update and
there's literally zero response in fact
sometimes only a teeny tiny
infinitesimal amount of their followers
are even seeing that update due to
algorithms on the other hand sometimes
that content goes out and it's just
massively
received you know people absolutely love
it and engage with it that
conversational response helps us
understand what in particular people
really like and what they care about so
there's also the idea of conversational
resonant this is the idea of which
topics in particular tend to produce
positive conversation or open the door
for more engagement so by taking the
time to look overall at the content you
have coming in and identify those places
where you see really really great
resonance really really high levels of
interest especially organically that's
one of those opportunities to look deep
and see what was the content what was it
we put
why did that resonate so well with
people and what do we do to create more
of that type of content sort of what's
the what's a happy medium of how often
we can leverage that before maybe we
push it a little too far and it loses
its value so again it's learning how to
identify some of those wins in the areas
of potential there's also the idea of
conversational direction this is
basically saying based on what we're
learning how are we going to adapt our
efforts moving forward what new
opportunities exist for content and for
campaigns where do we go next
you know what are we seeing get brought
up in a comment somewhere or you know
maybe we're looking on Pinterest and
we're seeing what's the name of the pin
board that they saved our content to
because maybe they're leveraging it in a
way that we didn't think about that
helps us know where we want to go next
now if we move on to the idea of
amplification rate to try and understand
what that looks like this becomes about
the idea of a combination of share and
reach because amplification is the
measurement of how far your message
manages to travel once you sort of
release it into the wild of social media
so this includes everyday sharing it
includes influencer exposure this
includes when things tend to go viral so
there's several things we want to look
at here one is the base level knowledge
that amplification is a strong indicator
of reception and value basically that
people like you people don't tend to
share content unless they find value in
it yes there's times where they share it
because they're upset or frustrated at
it but they're still finding some
measure of value worth engaging and
talking about so the amount of
amplification that's taking place is a
good indicator of how well your content
is resonating with people now
amplification rate is also a good
indicator of connection power in other
words how influential is your sort of
starting point base level visitors and
the people who tend to engage with you
and share your content because social
sharing might help you pick up some new
eyeballs but really strong amplification
that indicates pick up by influencers
and evangelists within a vertical or it
indicates an extraordinary amount of
interest that might go past what your
normal content tends to pull
no amplification looks different on
every network it's best measured on an
individual basis with different pieces
of content on those individual channels
overreach is a great sign of really
strong amplification overreach basically
means your message is getting to more
people than what that initial starting
point of your reach was meaning it's
extended past what you were capable of
doing on your own now when we look at
these different networks and we look at
what's going to sort of indicate that
amplification on facebook we're looking
at things like the shares per update on
Twitter it's about the retweets per
tweet on Instagram it's your regram on
Pinterest at your reap ins on YouTube
it's your shares you kind of get the
general idea here it's someone taking
what they found and passing it along to
the next person now when we look at a
channel like say YouTube we can take an
example video so for example the
crystallized video from Lindsey Stirling
we can see that she has 2.9 million
YouTube subscribers but when we look at
the reach of this individual video we
find that 70 million people viewed it
that's roughly 25 times her subscriber
count that's a pretty great indicator of
the amount of amplification that was
taking place with this particular video
it not only went past or you know not
only reached a good portion of who
followed them you know that her
followers themselves came in to watch it
not only went past that but it
completely blew it out of the water so
again great indicator of excellent
amplification now when we move on to the
idea of applause rate this comes down
the feedback this is less about sharing
or conversation and it's more about the
positive social reinforcement that takes
place on channel these are the likes the
favorites you know things like that
pause rate is an indicator of sentiment
or like-mindedness it's basically
approval that positive reinforcement
through social endorsements that serves
as a good indicator of the willingness
of your audience to communicate and of
what they like so again when we're we're
looking at a piece of content on YouTube
it's not just the amount of views it
gets it's also looking at what's the
thumbs up versus the thumbs down
because that's one of those things that
people look at when they land on the
content cocaine maybe a ton of people
watched it but did they like it so when
there's way higher thumbs up then there
are thumbs down that's a really good
indicator that's the applause rate that
says to someone this video is probably
going to be worth watching if they're
searching for something on Pinterest
they're going to look at the number of
reap ends and the number of favorites
and likes that are taking place because
that's an indicator of how many other
people have found this to be really
valuable content and that's going to
help give us that social sway to
determine whether or not we want to
engage with that individual piece of
content now applause rate much like some
of the other areas tends to be specific
to the individual social Channel you're
looking at so again on YouTube that's
going to be the thumbs up per video on
Pinterest it's going to be the number of
likes per video on Twitter it's the
favorites on Facebook it's the likes
proposed but it's really important to
remember that of all of the ones we've
talked about applause rate in particular
is not always a reliable indicator a lot
of that's going to depend on the
individual social channel that you're
looking at because the true value of a
pause rate is tied to that specific
channel it can really be a strong
indicator on Facebook or on YouTube
where people are used to giving the
thumbs up they're used to giving you
know clicking that like button but it's
less so on places like Pinterest and
Twitter where people tend to share their
their approval through the sharing
action so on Pinterest it's more likely
that they're going to reap n than it is
that they're going to click that like or
favorite button on Twitter they're more
likely to retweet something they're
really like or to respond to it then to
click that favorite button so you have
to have some understanding of the
channel that you're on and what you're
trying to measure to know whether or not
it really is going to give you that
reliable indicator of what your applause
rate looks like now wrapping it all up
it's really critical to remember that
there's a difference between
understanding measurements what we need
to measure sort of how we need to
measure between doing that as a marketer
versus doing that as an analyst because
an analyst clearly needs to have way
more tools and way deeper insight and
information here so if you're coming at
this from the
Marketing side this should give you that
base level knowledge and insight to be
able to go and talk to your digital
analysts to be able to say here's what
we're looking for to be able to help
interpret some of the data they bring
back to you
if on the other hand you're at a small
company where you rely on yourself to be
able to do the analytics to do the
measurement I'd really suggest that you
take the time to dig deeper by jumping
into our web analytics course here at
simply learned because there's going to
be a lot more detail a lot more
information and a lot more input on what
it looks like to really get in and
gather that data also consider taking a
look at the conversion optimization
course because that's where you're going
to learn a little bit more about things
like maybe split testing and what it
means to try this effort versus that
effort and to understand how that
factors in to the testing that goes
along with analytics now wrapping this
all up your key takeaways from this
video are one that it's rarely a good
idea to base your metrics off of
standard issue options you need to make
sure that you're using your campaign
goals to define the metrics that are
going to be worth tracking for you in
this particular circumstance number two
conversational value not only helps you
measure engagement it also helps you
identify the content that's making an
impact so that you can use that to plan
your future content strategy number
three amplification rate serves as a
really strong indicator of consumer Buy
in towards your content basically do
they like it do they approve of it and
do they think it's worthwhile to pass on
to others number four applause rate
tends to be the least accurate social
media specific metric but it does serve
as a very good indicator of interest and
offers the benefit of social proofing to
help sway engagement from users who come
in and see that applause rate in effect
and then finally while all marketers
need an understanding of measurement
it's best to work with a trained
analytics expert for your data or to
take the time to familiarize yourself
more deeply with what it looks like to
really dig into the data this concludes
lesson to social media specific metrics
with that we come to the end of section
10 social media measurement thank you so
much for joining in this section
[Music]
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here